can you ever see Reagan or Trump being a
VP
believe it or not I can see it more with
Reagan than with Trump with Trump it's
harder to see because of Just The Way
Trump is I mean Trump is the other thing
is when you see Trump he's a little
different you know I've had a chance I
didn't know Trump by the way when people
say I give you a pardon and so on when
Trump gave me a pardon I'd never met the
guy so so it wasn't like he was doing me
a favor or he owed me or anything like
that but since then I've gotten to gnome
a little better and he's he's a very
interesting fellow but he also is like
he marches to his own drummer and and
Reagan did not do that Reagan in in the
end was in fact a party man uh in fact
Reagan has famous statements where he
says things like never criticize your
own party you know that's the 11th
commandment of being a republican so
with Reagan let's just say in a freak
case had had Gerald Ford offered him the
vice president I think Reagan would have
taken it